a biden nomination filled with anti-cop
disinformation she's an ivy league
nominee who got schooled by our second
favorite kennedy
nominee
nusrat jahan chowdhury's past
anti-police comments came back to bite
her in the rear when louisiana senator
john kennedy committed the ultimate
crime repeating a leftist owned words
back to them
while at princeton chowdhury said quote
cops kill
unarmed black men in america every
single day
which led to a really simple question
this is a really simple question
councilman do you believe
that cops kill unarmed black men in
america every single day you said it at
princeton
senator i said it in my role as an
advocate oh okay you didn't mean
senator i said it in my role as an
advocate to make a rhetorical point
so so when you say something that's
incorrect it's okay to excuse it by
saying oh i was being an advocate what
do you believe do you personally believe
that cops
kill unarmed black men every single day
in america
which is either true or false according
to a fancy new technology called numbers
i wonder how she responded
senator i believe law enforcement have
an important and challenging job in this
country that's not what you said though
council
senator i say before you hear today that
i do believe law enforcement have a
difficult and challenging job and i also
understand the difference i just think
that's an extraordinary statement to
make with no data to back up
no none whatsoever
there's no basis for you saying that
and you knew it then and you know it now
how can someone possibly believe that
you're going to be unbiased on the
federal bench
well i don't think you can believe that
since she inflated the data like it was
a float in the thanksgiving day parade
surely she wasn't just making things up
to stick it to the cops
senator i believe my record shows that i
have worked collaboratively with law
enforcement in boston chicago
mississippi and milwaukee to solve
complex problems to promote
constitutional effectiveness your record
shows that you believe cops
are guilty until proven innocent
your record shows that if a cop
if if if if a cop shoots a criminal it's
the cops fault
and if a criminal shoots a cop it's the
gun's fault
i've read your record
i've read your record miss murr and i
don't appreciate you not answering the
question straight up i would respect you
a lot more if you just tell us what you
believe and not try to hide it
so basically her past comments don't
count because she set him as an advocate
which in this case means a liar
a quality you look for in a judge aside
from sobriety and looking hot in a black
robe
tyrus
was this just a
little bit of hyperbole
or was it part of
a larger narrative that fueled a rise in
crime and attacks on cops no it's not
hyperbole because uh look at
what the violence is happening with
police
men and women across this country it's
not those words matter
and he usually he says you know he goes
off in his weird little places but
he was dead on but
i think and it goes back to what i said
a couple nights ago like we need to
redefine what words actually mean
because i didn't know advocate meant i
could say whatever i want so
could you imagine you're in court and
like why excuse me earl why did you burn
down tyrus's house and have a cross in
front well i i did that as an advocate
for the clan that wasn't me i was doing
that and
well case dismissed he was an advocate
he's probably an advocate as long as
you're advocating around there's no you
know you can say whatever you want so i
think
just the fact that she said that with a
straight face is just shocking yeah
again it goes back to the same thing
nobody they'll say anything they don't
want any responsibility for it they
don't own it it doesn't have to be true
and if you call him on it he's the bad
guy yeah he's being racist i guarantee
you that was how they're gonna spin it
he attacked her he attacked a woman of
color yes
and that but she was but he was an
advocate yes he was an advocate for
for a misogynistic male yes it wasn't
him he was advocating yeah you know uh
douglas what if she had actually tried
to defend herself like when he was going
i would respect you more if you would
just tell but do you i mean they never
do no they just back up and they just go
uh they have their canned statement yes
you know she's worked with police in
milwaukee that that that was what yes
that worked out really well yeah um no
i i wish they would just admit it but it
would be humiliating yeah she should say
okay look i was very uh whipped up at
that point and i wanted to whip a lot of
other people up as well and so i made
stuff up and wildly lied about the cops
because it was just that season and it
made me feel good that would be honest
yeah it would be honestly looking back
she could just say and looking back on
it i regret it yeah looking back on it i
was being stupid and uh and foolish and
so but they never do do that they just
okay they say oh that was a that's
different that was a advocate speech
whatever no i mean i have unending
contempt for these people who lie about
this country lie about the police lie
about this country's history and
whenever they're caught out on it they
just
they they won't own it yeah they won't
own it
and cat she may end up becoming a judge
unlike you
a truth teller i got time yeah yeah
are you you playing i'd be a great job
you're playing the slow game yeah you're
waiting it out
you still have to go to law school uh
yeah but
that's dumb because i already like i
could do law yeah it's very judgmental
yeah i could do it
i could be like okay you're good you're
not good that's how i would say it
excellent yeah yes but as an advocate if
she's an advocate she's also bad at that
because there are real conversations we
can and should have about you know
racial disparities in the criminal
justice system but the best way to
prevent that is to flood it full of
obviously you know proven false stuff
like what she said because then the
conversation becomes about that so if
shirley was an advocate you know you
would want to talk about the truth and
there's plenty of things you can say but
i i just i don't understand why she
can't nobody can ever just say yeah you
know
yeah nobody can ever say that
[Music]
i say it all the time yeah i didn't know
we could say stuff on this show oh i say
it all well when you do that's good
i'm glad to know that
or you could just say i advocated yes
sorry
no
salu they found the study that uh when
they uh polled democrats they actually
believed that thousands of unarmed black
men were murdered every year and that
where did this come from it came from
this kind of commentary from people that
are supposed to know better so she had
blue blood on her hands that's hyperbole
she also could have said i'm not the
first person to say that yeah
we hear this kind of stat every day yeah
but i think i owe an apology to the
intellectual heavyweight known as the
lady in the first segment
[Laughter]
this woman outshines her it's quite
amazing yeah that's true although they
use similar logic because mary poppins
lady
she was challenged people said oh but
she
gave disinformation out on through her
twitter feed and when she was live
tweeting the debate and she said that
the hunter laptop was disinformation and
so someone called her out on it and her
answer was uh guys i was live tweeting
was advocating yeah i was advocating wow
but you know maybe i do that too when
it's like if i say something it's no
that's not i was thinking on tv
you can like say things and go dude i'm
on tv that's something i've literally
never heard you say that no and i'm
trying to be nice if you're wrong you'll
have a follow-up monologue talking about
it you're talking about it yeah yeah
basically i try to you really don't
advocate for anything
he also doesn't want to give that kind
of consideration or forgiveness to
anybody else that's a good yeah that's a
good job when she's in her bubble they
all say that yeah they all say
all those falsehoods and they cheer each
other on for it i was drunk is a valid
excuse yes that is true no i was
advocating for beer
i don't i don't think judges can say i
was drunk
you can in my court
in a new cat called
tim's drinking court
i feel a fox nation show fox nation
judge
tim's drinking court
and they drink while they settle dispute
and
yeah i'm gonna get shot every time you
say guilty yes exactly all right up next
a tweet from a twit when a toy fooled a
brit oh we're gonna bash the brits hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else